Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Nick from
Harlem? Nick, welcome to the program. What can
I do for you today?
Speaker 2:
Hey there. Can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, the first time in a long
time. Thank you so much for your work.
Actually, I have a question about
the Pokemon Finance channel. Sure.
So I know you have a background and you
have an educational background in finance,
and I don't know if you've ever tie or if you
teach courses, but for me, the part of financial
has been like an educational experience,
as I'm sure is one of your intentions. Yes,
I've even had the opportunity to like, share
it with some of my conservative conservative,
I guess I would say acquaintances. And, you know,
they end up also turning into other, you know,
the other Pacman channel, your main channel.
And that, you know, it's kind of I found that
of to be interesting. And my question is, I guess,
would you ever consider doing an all in aspect for
Pacman finance like not necessarily a financial
advice but just you know how to or, you know,
if folks kind of have, you know, specific
questions about their specific situations. I
don't know what what your thoughts around that.
Speaker 1: It is something I would consider.
The thing you've got to be really careful
about is you don't want to end up giving
financial advice in a context where then it blows
up on you, you know, in some way. Yeah, but it
would be at least conceivably super interesting.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. Thank you. And then I have
one other quick question for you. Sure.
Speaker 1: Please.
Speaker 2: Ah, so I'm here. You know, in New
York, we have an oversight agency of the police
department called the Civilian Complaint Review
Board, and they're considered to be one of the,
I guess, what you would say, premier agencies
in the country when it comes to oversight
of police misconduct. Mm hmm. And so but what
I'm seeing a lot is folks criticizing them for
being ineffective. And there there's legislation
actually in the state that's trying to remove the
agency and replace it with something else. And so
my question is not specifically about the agency,
but it's about the idea. And I think
I've heard you say this once before about
if we are going to we can criticize, for example,
Biden for policies and stuff like that. But
if we don't have something to replace it with,
what are what are we to do? You know? And it's
like it just frustrates me a lot of the time that
people want to criticize like some, you know,
philosophies or certain things that are existing,
not even the philosophy, like things are in place,
but how are you going to replace what you're
criticizing and what is you know, and how do
you suppose people can deal with that? Or as a
movement of progressives even, you know, well.
Speaker 1: You're getting at something that
is you know, it's one of these truisms where
it's very it's much easier to criticize than
it is to come up with solutions to problems.
And that doesn't necessarily mean that
just because you've identified a problem,
but you don't have a solution, you should be
ignored. I mean, it's it's not that like let
me give you an example. This is it's it's sort of
it's kind of silly, but it also makes sense. You
could be watching a car race, a NASCAR race, and
know nothing about NASCAR vehicles, but identify
a car that has something wrong with it. It's like
wobbling down the track and it's slower than all
the others and there's blue smoke coming out of
it. Even without knowing much about how to fix
that problem, you could identify that something
is wrong. So I don't want to laugh off the fact
that it's totally legit to say, Hey, you know
what? The status quo with student lending isn't
working. You've got all these people, they take
out these student loans. College is outrageously
expensive. They graduate, they have a crazy debt,
but the job they get doesn't pay much money. Debt.
It's great that we can identify that. You don't
necessarily need to know whether the solution
comes from regulation or a higher minimum wage
or making it harder to borrow or putting price
caps on colleges or creating a job market that's
more robust for non-college job. You don't have to
know the answer to be able to identify a problem.
So I don't think that it's useful to just say,
Hey, just pointing out problems doesn't
really have value. However, if you're in
a position of power as an elected official or
you're arguing that you should be voted into
a position of power, you damn well better have
some suggestions as to how to fix the problem.
Speaker 2: And that makes absolutely no sense
to me. Thank you for that and thank you. I
appreciate that. That makes a lot of sense.
Speaker 1: All right, Nick from Harlem,
thanks for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, there he goes. Now on to
all sorts of other things. Nick from Harlem.
Let's go to Chris from Georgia. Chris
from Georgia. Welcome to the program.
I'll let you get settled here and unmute yourself.
What's on your mind today? Chris from Georgia,
you're on. I can't hear you, though. Probably
you have your wrong audio device selected.
Chris from Georgia, Welcome to the show.
All right. And there goes. Chris from
Georgia. That's sad. I'm sad we weren't
able to make the connection. Let's go to Ty
from Iowa. Ty from Iowa. Welcome. What's going
on? David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Okay. So I wanted to ask this.
I just thought this was kind of weird.
Speaker 2: So I notice, you know, how.
Speaker 3: Like a lot of Republicans will say,
like, well, the Democrats are just communists
and socialists and all this stuff, Right?
Yeah. So I think it's kind of weird. Like,
I remember Trump put out that one thing and
he said, like, China would have never flew a
spy a spy balloon over me because China.
Speaker 2: Respects me too much. Yeah.
Speaker 3: I just thought that
was really kind of weird to hear.
Speaker 1: Well, it's absurd. I mean, we have we
since found out that China did fly spy balloons
during Trump's term. TRUMP Apparently they did.
Trump apparently wasn't told about it, which
fine. But the idea that they respect him too much
or fear him too much, and this actually gets to a
broader issue of of the idea of fear as the way
to get power and respect in politics. You know,
fear. And this came up during my interview on
the Patrick David podcast where he said, Is it
bad that nobody fears the U.S. anymore? And I was
like, Well, what evidence do you have of that? He
was like, Forget it. You know, like we got off
on to a different thing. But fear will make your
adversaries and allies involve you only
enough to minimize the threat from you,
but not enough to make you a serious participant.
And so like the fear example. Let's let's grant
maybe other countries were afraid of Trump. They
were afraid because he was so unstable. And that
only gets them to deal with Trump in a way that
will be the minimum to prevent him from doing
something completely insane. But he'll never be
taken seriously when fear is the main thing that
goes on. And so that's why I think that this idea
of fear to gain power is fundamentally flawed.
Speaker 3: And it just was kind of weird to hear
because it's kind of like he it seems like he'll
praise China when need be, but then he'll also say
that the Democrats are communists. But then it's
like, well, you're you're praising this thing
that to you is like a far left dictatorship.
Doesn't really make a lot of sense.
Speaker 1: Right. Absolutely.
Yeah, I think so. So that's my view on
that. I hope I've answered your question.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that makes sense.
Speaker 1: All right, Ty from Iowa,
thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There he goes. Some
pretty solid calls today, I must say.